that is is the rub right now with with
black lives matter because
when you go to the black lives matter
the organization's website
right and then i'm not talking about you
know the don lemons running cover for
them in the media i'm not talking about
when you go to the organization's
website
they say things like they're in favor of
abolishing the nuclear family
um centering lgbtqia
plus queer people all of this stuff all
of this stuff
that the vast majority of regular
working class black americans
are not super into or even downwards so
there is a lot of that
tension there
let's make this about us for a second so
if you take two guys like if you take
two guys like us you take dave rubin you
take rob smith
and you go wait a minute these guys sort
of seem like what would be
i think you could call sort of new
conservatives something like that
we don't look like you know we're both
married to dudes that's a little
different than
uh you know traditional conservatism um
what do you think what do you think our
kind of
new role or the younger newer
conservative role is
within the conservative okay so this is
what i think
and i've been i think about this a lot
and it's like
everything that i'm doing from from from
here on out with with
everything that we'll be talking about a
little bit is about this so it's like
how do we usher in the conservative
movement in conservative movement into
this new era where
you got more black people you got more
more people of color you got more gays
you got whatever
and i think that what we do is
we define a love for country and a love
for america that is not
completely uncritical but it is not
based in some sort of idea that it was
created to permanently and perpetually
keep people like us in some way
oppressed because i think that
the um and i was speaking with uh with
with uh lara trump earlier about this
thing so this is about creating a more
perfect union
so this is not about pretending that
america was always perfect this is about
this is about perfecting this union and
we have to open up this idea of the
american experiment to everybody
because what the left says right now to
people like you and people like me
and and a lot of different people is
that america
was never for you america is not for you
you cannot survive here you cannot exist
here
this uh system is racist and the only
way that you will ever be free or be
successful
is if you join with us in tearing this
all down via via socialism leptism
whatever you want to call it
and so our job is to reach out to to not
only to people like us but also
these mainstream conservatives that look
like your typical conservative they
those people make up a lot of the people
that follow both of us
and so and to kind of bring everybody
into this idea of of
what is america and how do we love
america
from all vantage points yeah i think the
hard part for some people when when they
see what you know people like
we are doing people like us i think the
hard part is they go well wait a minute
there's still such a strong religious
bent
right that this just doesn't make sense
they think you guys are sinners
something like that and people go well
reuben how can you be friends with
shapiro and it's like yes he has a
different
view of biblical marriage but he's not
trying to legislate my life
it does put a cap on our friendship
right i can be friends with you in a way
that i can't be with him because of that
thing but it's
but it doesn't but i know he's way more
tolerant than all the other people that
are screaming about tolerance all the
time
but what would you say to if a young a
young gay person
that is trying to become part of this or
or understand this
what would you say to them about that i
would say to them that that first of all
just like you articulated it
pretty well um is that a difference of
opinion
and actively legislating against things
there are two different things right
and you know it gets into the religious
freedom conversation which is a whole
other conversation as well
but this is what i say to the the
younger gay person that
is reaching out to me that may be
leaning conservative and that has
problems with the religious thing first
of all
i tell them number one you know you're
jewish i'm christian
i i think that the left in the far left
uses um they use this this idea
that most uh evangelical christians are
super far right hate gay people all of
that stuff
to separate them from the gift that is
having a connection to
whatever your belief is for me it's that
belief in christianity and the belief in
god
and they would want to separate these
guys
these young um gays and lesbians from
that
so that they can worship at the altar of
leptism
so that they can worship at the author
alter politics so that they they can
worship
at the altar of as i always call it the
lgbtq cult
so they want these kids worshiping at
that altar
and not uh at the altar of of their
creator whoever they believe that they
may be
if that makes any sense at all and i'll
tell you furthermore
that i have made inroads
with a lot of these conservative
christians and they'll say look
i still believe like you and and bin
shapiro even though
uh you and bishop parable jewish i'll
have these conversations with these
conservative christians and they'll say
i my belief is that marriage is between
a man and a woman that is what i believe
but you go ahead and live your best
life and if neither of us are hurting
each other we can coexist
and that is tolerant
that is tolerance that that is america
uh you know it's like i
i spoke at liberty university the
largest evangelical college in the
united states in front of 14
000 kids it was like a true political
rally the biggest crowd i've ever spoken
front of
and they freaking loved me and i went
around campus all day long shaking hands
and hugging people and and
it was great and it's like those are the
intolerant people i think we're doing
something backwards over here
yeah maybe um and it seems like nowadays
like look the
the most intolerant people are on the
left these are the people that are the
most intolerant these are the people
that are
the most likely to throw out slurs you
know you're homophobe racist
nazi all of this other stuff the people
who
even slightly um disagree with any of
their stuff or or even
gently call out leftist policies this is
what they do if these are shut down
terms
i hope that they start to mean less
um as we move into this this new world
we're trying to get into
yeah so i know you hate sort of the
phrase community whether we say the
black community or the lgbt community
because we are all individuals
ultimately
yeah but sometimes sometimes we just
need some of these words to
to explain situations but do you sense a
really weird
tension in the black community related
to
identity because of color and then the
sexuality thing because
it seems to me and we keep seeing videos
of this pop up online
where there'll be black people that are
suddenly they're stuck in this
intersectional thing and they're
suddenly going no i have traditional
you know beliefs and i'm not down with
all that lgbt
stuff and and these things have been
sort of morphed into a very weird thing
where suddenly if you if you're you have
to be
suddenly black trans lives matter i'm
personally fine with black trans people
of course
but suddenly they create this thing
where it's just like you have to be for
all of these things no matter what your
other set of beliefs
are so that is
is the rub right now with with black
lives matter because
when you go to the black lives matter
the organization's website
right and then i'm not talking about you
know the don lemons running cover for
them in the media i'm not talking about
when you go to the organization's
website
they say things like they're in favor of
abolishing the nuclear family
um centering lgbtqia
plus queer people all of this stuff all
of this
stuff that the vast majority of
regular working-class black americans
are not
super into or even down with so there is
a lot of that tension there
um in this is the problem with
when you let brands organizations and
corporations define
black because black lives matter does
not define black
my blackness is not defined by black
lives matter any of their founders or
any of the people that
have you know put themselves in the
position to speak for this
organization like i said there's an
organization as a corporation
um there's a business and they don't
speak for me so there
is a lot of tension there and
furthermore so i talk a lot about i say
lgbtq cults a lot right
um so there are gays and they're
lesbians and they're bisexuals and
they're transgender people most of which
are
law-abiding tax-paying citizens that
just want to live their lives and
pretty much be left alone then there is
the lgbtq cult
and the cultists say that you will
listen to whatever we
say whatever we change is the idea so
if we want to use pronouns this is what
you call us or else we will find you
um if you do not agree with adding
transgender women to
the spaces for actual women you are now
transphobic and it is all of that stuff
that is going
crazy and and it's stuff and i break
this down there's a whole chapter in
this book called
escaping the lgbtq cult where i kind of
break all that stuff down and that is
the stuff
that most people are not down with most
people don't care
about gays and lesbians we're past that
point now but they see all the cult
stuff
and they think that that represents all
of us and it just doesn't
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell